let's say I start a money market mutual
fund and I initially capitalize it with
nine million dollars so I have nine
million dollars of assets right now and
it's cash right when I started off and
I'm also going to have and this tends to
be the case for money market mutual
funds is I will create nine million
shares or nine million units so I will
divide this up into nine million nine
million shares so right from the get-go
my net asset value so my asset value is
nine million I have no liabilities to
subtract from that so my net asset value
is going to be the same as my asset
value and so my net asset value per
share my nav per share is going to be
nine million dollars over nine million
shares or one dollar one dollar per
share and I'm gonna take this this money
and I'm going to invest it in t-bills
and commercial paper and CDs things that
are very liquid short-term and very very
very safe and as interest comes in as
interest comes in on those on those
assets from the government or from the
corporations or wherever I'm getting
that from I pay them as dividends to the
owners of these units or the owners of
the shares so they get dividends and so
it doesn't automatically although you
could set it up so it automatically does
it but in general it won't go right back
into the asset pool so it'll just stay
at $1 if my asset pool will just stay at
the or the my nav per share will just
stay at $1 now this is the case of
almost all money market funds you're
almost all of the time but every now and
then something really wild might happen
so they might invest in super safe
things like tea bills or commercial
paper commercial paper short-term loans
to very safe companies commercial paper
and something really wild might happen
like it looks like the United States
government in its history all of a
sudden for the first time ever might
default on its debt or maybe it actually
does default on its debt
and if something like that were to
happen then this thing that people
thought was that they people thought was
as good as cash
all of a sudden might go down in value
or you might have a financial crisis
where for whatever reason whatever
reason people are dumping people are
dumping commercial paper no one wants to
hold it anymore
and so this value might go down so it's
only happened very very very very few
times and even then it wasn't a dramatic
move you could imagine a world where the
actual nav goes below the or the actual
nav per share goes below this one dollar
and when that happens that's called
breaking the buck breaking the buck and
most mutual fund companies that run a
money market fund like this even if
something disastrous like this happened
and these this fund goes from $1 nav per
share to 93 cents or 95 cents nav per
share it's such a bad it's such a bad
signal to customers that this thing that
you were marketing is essentially as
good as cash as good as a savings
account is all of a sudden something
that someone might lose money on what
tends to happen and this is why it's
there's been so few times in history
where investors actually lost money on
money market funds if even if these
things do lose value the parent company
of the money market fund usually makes
them whole they usually say look it's it
might cost us a little bit money to make
this share or make this fund whole but
that's less than the cost that or the
harm to our actual reputation but once
again I want to emphasize this has
happened very very very few times in
history